y bing de noruega me ha pedido que
hagamos otro problema de sustitución un
lo cual me gusta pues aprovechamos la
inercia que tenemos para realizar este
tipo de problemas el problema que él
envió y espero haya pronunciado bien su
nombre es encontrar la integral
indefinida de seno de x
/ coseno de x al cuadrado de x lo que es
igual así fue como lo puso él en su
correo electrónico a la integral de seno
de x
/ con seno cuadrado de x de x
me gusta más esta forma es menos ambigua
de cualquier manera cuando hacemos
integración por sustitución o cuando
vemos un término necesitamos buscar su
derivada en ese integrando así si este
coseno de x fuera una x fuera una u esta
integral sería fácilmente realizable
déjame hacerlo aquí al lado esto hace
muy fácil es la anti derivada de uno
entre x cuadrada de x la actividad de un
matrix cuadrada de x que ya sabemos cómo
hacerlo lo planteamos como la anti
derivada de x a la menos 2 de x
y ya sabemos cómo tomar la anti derivada
de algo así sumamos un al exponente y
multiplicamos por el nuevo exponente
tendremos entonces menos x
perdón sumas un al exponente y divides
entre el nuevo exponente
hagámoslo entonces así sumamos 1 el
exponente entonces menos dos más uno
menos uno y dividido entre menos uno nos
da menos x al menos uno más para
verificar esto tomamos la derivada menos
1 x menos 1 nos da positivo y menos uno
menos 1 tenemos menos 2 que es el
exponente
así es que si llevamos está integrada la
que se vea de esta manera ya le hicimos
vemos un patrón donde hay x tenemos
coseno de x y su derivada que es seno de
x que ese es el secreto para hacer
integral por sustitución así es que en
este caso haremos la sustitución o igual
a coseno de x
entonces tomamos como
igual coseno de x y la derivada de v con
respecto a x
dv
en de x
más exactamente seno de x recordemos que
la derivada de coseno de x con respecto
x es menos seno
y multiplicando ambos lados por de x
obtenemos de v es igual a menos seno de
x
de equis
multiplicamos lados por de equis pero
aquí tenemos seno de x de x
entonces lo voy a reescribir voy a
reescribir aquí
integral de seno de x
p x entre coseno vx al cuadrado
pero si queremos esto y por esto tenemos
menos seno de x así es que multiplicamos
por menos 1 ambos lados menos de v es
igual a seno de x de x
así es que escribamos esta expresión
hagámoslo aquí abajo pues me estoy
quedando corto de espacio sabemos que es
igual a coseno de x entonces esta
integral la podemos describir como la
integral de
como es igual a coseno de x entonces lo
que tenemos en el denominador es
al cuadrado
lo hicimos coseno de equis y tenemos
aquí seno de x de x que equivale seno de
x de x aquí lo vemos menos dv es igual a
cero de x de x
así es que sustituimos en esta integral
menos déu y esto tiene la forma de lo
que hicimos acá que es la integral de 1
- 1 sobre o al cuadrado dv lo cual
también lo podemos reescribir son varias
formas equivalentes como la integral de
menos o a la menos 2
dv
y hacemos lo mismo que hicimos aquí
arriba tenemos un signo menos que nos va
a facilitar las cosas de tal manera que
encontramos la anti derivada general de
esta expresión igual a menos 2 le vamos
a una potencia más 1 el exponente
entonces vuela menos dos más uno nos
quedaría como al menos uno tenemos que
dividir entre el nuevo exponente
dividimos entre menos uno y tenemos un
signo menos en la expresión original que
no incluimos aquí por supuesto más c y
éste menos uno que tenemos aquí dividido
entre menos uno se cancelan y entonces
tenemos como resultado la menos uno más
o su equivalente que es uno entre uno
más
y esa es la antigüedad general de esto
pero ojo no hemos acabado todavía pues
tenemos una situación que hicimos que es
la sustitución de igual a coseno de x
de tal manera que nuestro resultado se
transforma entonces en 1 / coseno de x
así
la cual es el resultado de la anti
deriva original que es la integral de
seno de x pongo en verde seno de x sobre
coseno de x al cuadrado de x en la
tienes nos vemos en el próximo vídeo